and oh what the [ __ ] is your aunt's name
chin in it what is it Hana aunt Anna and
Hana Hana any god damn
with all respect King yeah bro give it
up give it up give it up with your
sweats bro - knees knocking new chin was
hole now dude your aunt
you [ __ ] some houses and this is no
disrespect
zero bro is she single
now she's not saying she's married to
your uncle snared my uncle you have kids
they got kids you're [ __ ] right they
do look at that mommy leave that [ __ ]
mom she a blood aunt yeah damn she's
syringe this part a little bit of Korean
in there god damn I bet I'd chop it down
brother [ __ ] right you would oh I'd
share a [ __ ] double scoop orange
chicken with her and talk about things
oh I karate kick her right into my bed
bro what I'm talking about is she seemed
like a nice lady dude I'd watch a
marathon of [ __ ] The Last Samurai
weather with my dick out flaunt my aunt
yeah this is all good bro these are
compliments where did she go to school
at Harvard in Texas I've never heard of
it Harvard well there's a lot of schools
in Texas and there's a lot of not
schools in Texas um she looks like a
nice lady did she bartend or not I think
was younger she [ __ ] right she's
Irish made Bank bro what's your uncle
look like curricular dude
oh yeah the Asian or not is the ice is
he out kicking his coverage coverage
yeah yeah like yeah he's a lucky dude
I'd say he's pretty lucky he looks like
[ __ ] he's lucky my uncle's it look like
[ __ ] the wrong with that her it's flaunt
your on yes say something nice about
that I've been I've been dating a lot
[ __ ] behind her at a bar no I did it
you asked if she weren't if she [ __ ]
could put tequila together does she
drink a lot I don't [ __ ] know she
does she go to a lot of rain
she'd do a lot of ecstasy on the
weekends [ __ ] I don't know man but she
looks like she's down get down to
hanging out and have a good time
yeah she's how old is she yeah that's a
good question I think maybe in like mid
40 mm thing about Asians bro you me get
you an agent deal you cannot tell they
don't age but then 80 comes boom
Cinderella
father time they age like fruit oh they
disappear tonight they turn into a
yellow squash but I'll say this dude
whoo chanting actually 40s if not know
Jesus and we shot a bocce
it seemed like she was in the gold rush
or something she has a very you know
kind of authentic sort of look kind of
you know her hair used to be like up
here the Texas big Texas hair
so she's trimmed it down a little bit
but it's still high and she has a little
bit of southern twang to that Texas
twine sure man honey calls her own honey
week she looks like she meat makes a
mean [ __ ] Bitsy's than crazy she
makes such good food and his food rescue
see that there she makes brisket the
best his wifey son how many kids of
three and they're all your age now no
they're younger oh yeah I could see that
damn she seemed like somebody that would
get water from the river and like just
ya know medicine does she know anything
about medicine or Mis does she like she
gives a natural cures now it's like she
gives a good back rub and then reads
[ __ ] tarot cards she's strong
oh dude I'd let that lady beat the [ __ ]
out of me to just you know come through
you know ii know probably a little
[ __ ] knew it man she looks like it can
handle herself
oh I'd let her run over me with a car
until I came do it I would I would share
a full rack of ribs with a Chili's
wouldn't give a [ __ ] yeah she seems like
a nice lady and a melon
she seems super nice yeah flaunt my own
flop my aunt shut up the chins on shout
out to [ __ ] Nick's grandma for the
side kick they're right the aunt just
got out Shawn shopping it's grandma bro
hey dude I think we got a segment here
though bro okay I got height for your
family bro I got height for your family
bro
no I can't think about chins out and
Nick's grandma bro I just want Nick and
Jenna to make it out of here safely
thank God me too I went there the same
DNA in
[Music]